Hey everybody, it's Mike from
Orderflows, and welcome to this replay
of the webinar I did earlier on the
Orderflows Power Bars. Now, I apologize
for those of you that were online. There
was a issue that I had with sharing my
screen. So, you know, it's much to
my
chagrin, what I was talking about wasn't
being projected onto, you know,
everybody at home. And I didn't realize
it until a bit later. And so, I had to
end it early, and I I just you know,
actually went about 45 minutes, and then
I I realized what was going on and the
issue. So, I just find it easier to
record this one now. So, again, you
know, those that stuck around,
thank you. And you know, those that
didn't, you know, I hope you enjoy this
presentation. So, what I'm going to talk
about today is the Orderflows Power
Bars. And what it is is it's it's a new
indicator that I released earlier this
week that helps traders trade order flow
around value. Okay? Now, if you're not
familiar with what value is in the
market, you know, a lot of traders
nowadays like to use volume profile, but
volume profile is sort of a offspring of
market profile, which came out I think
what in the 1980s.
It just sort of morphed more into volume
profile. Now, people that use
market profile,
you know, they're really die hard, you
know, they really
um
understand markets, right? Because they
understand where value is in the market,
you know, and I think that's where a lot
of traders get lost out there. They're
so busy following price. Oh, the price
traded here, price traded there. You
know, they're quote following price
action. Well,
value is more important than price
action, you know, if
once you understand value, right?
Because you understand what something is
worth. All right? So, for example, I I
just drove up from Orlando to Chicago
the last couple of days, and you know, I
stopped in Georgia cuz my wife is like,
I want to eat some peach ice cream,
okay? Cuz we're in Georgia, right? And
they grow peaches there. Well, I stopped
at this nice farm, and you know, they
also got other vegetables for sale.
And I I I just you know, me, I just want
to
vegetables, so I'm like, I'll buy this,
buy that. My wife is like, what that's
so expensive, you know, for this okra.
I'm like, yeah, but it looks so nice.
She's like, well, it's cheaper where we
live. Okay.
So, I I didn't buy it because she
understood the value, you know, me, I
just you know, I
I'm attracted to it. But when you
understand value, you understand that,
you know, you're going to buy things
that are below value.
Or you know, you're going to buy
something you you have in your mind what
value is, right? So, say for example,
this pack of okra was, I don't know, I
don't remember the price, but say it was
$5. You know, she's like, well, you
know, hey, it's $3 where I do my grocery
shopping. Okay, you know, even though
you're saving $2, but you know, over
time, you know, $2 here, $2 there adds
up. And you know, when you understand
value, then
you know, you got to understand just
because a market trades a price, it
doesn't mean necessarily that's what
it's worth, okay? Because you know,
value is
shifting. Value is always shifting, and
you know, something that people that
that trade with volume profile,
I think, you know, a big mistake that
they have is
they just look at the volume profile for
the day and just go from there. And you
got to realize
days start different times for different
traders. All right? And and you could
even have people that
are trading value area for the last
month. They're not necessarily trading
it for the day, you know, or you know,
maybe some guy in Asia is trading
the value based on the Asian hours, or
some guy in Europe is trading S&Ps
during the US hours, but he starts his
value at when he sat down at the desk in
London in the morning. All right? So,
value isn't fixed in stone where it
starts right when the day begins, okay?
And
you know, and I I see it also with VWAP,
right? A lot of traders like to use VWAP
now. You know, that's that's the the new
thing that everyone's, you know, over
the last few years, oh, VWAP, VWAP this,
VWAP that. You know, you got to trade
reversion to the mean. Well, later in
the day, you know, if you ever watch
VWAP, right? It's volume weighted
average price.
But
late in the day, when 80% of the volume
is already traded, it's not going to
move very much. It gets flat late in the
day, all right? Whereas if you're
trading VWAP around, you know, 8:30
right after the cash opens,
VWAP's going to fluctuate more, okay?
You're going to have more movement
earlier in the day than than later in
the day cuz it's it's flatlining not
flatlining, but it's gone flat. Okay?
So, you got to understand that. And you
know, the way big traders use VWAP,
you know, the the
the majority of traders use it as a
measure of um execution, right? So, you
know, the big trader at Tudor calls his
brokers, yeah, sell me 3,000 S&Ps over
the next 15 minutes, okay? So, it starts
at, you know, he gives me the order at
right now, 5:00, I think it's 5:11 right
now in Chicago. He's like, you got 15
minutes to do it. So, by 5:26, I should
be done.
Okay? Cuz that's his parameters.
And he's going to I'm going to come back
to him with the fill. Oh, your average
price is 4234.45.
Well, he's going to say, well, VWAP was
4234.01.
You know, why are you off almost half a
point above VWAP, you know? That's how
the big traders use it. I mean, you
know, there's other ways that they use
it, but that's the main way that is
being used. Oh, you know, they're not
looking at VWAP since the market opened
and saying, well, where you are, you
know, above or below VWAP since the
market opened. They're concerned with
where VWAP was during that time period,
okay? And the power bar sort of takes
that concept of where value is over this
most recent period. It's it's not I'm
not concerned with where, you know,
value was
at 9:00 in the morning when it's 2:00 in
the afternoon because it could be so far
away from value, it's not going to
matter. All right? That yeah, okay,
well, we're 30 points away from value
right now. Well, there's no point in
looking at value because you're so far
away from it, right? But as a trader, if
you could see, well, oh, you know, what?
Value over the last few minutes, the
last 5 minutes, 15 minutes is this.
You know, it's six, but we're trading
seven
or eight, right? How can you take that
relationship and you know, trade around
it? So,
let's take a look at this the the
indicator, okay? Adding the indicator is
really very easy, right? You just import
it as you would any other tool. Now, I
already have it on my computer here. So,
you just click NinjaTrader add-ons. I'm
not going to add it on again, but I'll
just take you through the steps. You
just find it on your computer. Again,
you know, you download it, save it to
your downloads file, then you click
open. I'm not going to do that now cuz
it's already there.
Um and then you just pull up a new
chart, okay? Chart.
You scroll from your control panel. Now,
the difference with
power bars and a lot of almost all my
other indicators is you don't need to
use tick replay, right? People have been
saying, Mike, you know, tick replay is
good, but it slows down my computer.
You know, I don't know what they got in
there for a natural chip or something
for their computer.
Cuz I don't have, you know, very fancy I
I just got i7s, I got i5s,
um Pentium uh Pentiums. Uh
it's
old I am. You know, those very few
remember those old
486s. I used to have one of those. But
um you know, I I don't have
top-of-the-line $3,000 trading
computers, you know, I I have you know,
my laptop I just bought at Best Buy a
couple years ago, and and I still use
it, and I still run NinjaTrader on it
when I travel. All right? Honestly, I
get a lot of my computers online from
TigerDirect, or I'm in Chicago, so I go
to Micro Center to buy something. Um you
know, you don't need
a super fast computer to run
NinjaTrader. I mean, there's nothing
wrong with it. You can if you have the
money to spend on it, but I I just think
that it's, you know, a bit overkill, you
know, I work at JP Morgan, you know, our
computers
were not top-of-the-line.
Um
you know, they don't have graphics cards
to add more screens, you know, I'd have
to literally when someone would transfer
lose their job, I would I'd get the
computer guy to go over there and see
what the person had under their screen
to get it on on my computer. But anyway,
I'm digressing. You don't need tick
replay. So, you know, people that on
slower computers for whatever reason
don't have to worry about running tick
replay. So, you can see it's unchecked,
okay? So, I'm just going to open a
normal bar chart, okay? So, this is a
normal bar chart here. It's on my other
screen. Let me just drag it in here,
okay?
Let's make it a bit bigger. Uh well,
make it as big as the screen.
There we go, okay? Now, this is, you
know, NinjaTrader, the default is a
black background, okay? Um
you know, the fonts I find a bit small.
So, what you got to do, again, you you
could change it. Um you just go into
properties, click on the screen, go on
to properties. I like to have fonts
bigger. I I've
I wear glasses, but still um
eight's kind of small, or you know, I
like to have it 18. I like to see things
basically on my screen. So, you know,
it's bigger. Now, we'll keep it black
for now, just so you can um
understand cuz the defaults are set for
a black screen. So, you just go under
indicators to add it.
I've already imported it. And you just
go up here. It's at the top in this
folder called Orderflows. It's not going
to be somewhere down here under
Orderflows. You just find it up here at
the top.
Power Bar version 1.1. Make sure it
appears down here.
Now, your license key is just going to
be your last name, you know, after you
purchase it, I'll register your name.
Just your last name. My last name is
Voltos, and I click um enable license
right here.
Click apply.
And click okay, and you can see it on
the screen. Now, the
colors Now, these are power bars, okay?
So, the the coloring the bar a certain
color, cyan for bullish or magenta
for bearish. Now,
people say, "Well, why cyan and you
know, why magenta?" Well,
NinjaTrader uses green for up candles
and red for down candles. Again, you
could adjust the colors. You know, say
you don't want to use
cyan.
Okay? You don't want to use magenta.
Okay, well, you just pull up the
properties. You change it to whatever
color you want. Say you want to use
blue, right? Say, "Oh, I don't like
magenta, Mike. I want to use a different
color." Okay, well,
pick your pick your color.
You know, maybe you want to use
orange. I don't know. You know, it's up
to you. Change it, right?
Then you just click apply.
And you can see blue and orange. Again,
it really depends on what you want to
use, but for now, I'll just keep the
defaults to cyan and magenta. If you're
using a white screen, you probably don't
want to use cyan. You should probably
use blue.
But again, that's up to you.
Um
So, we'll start out here with just the
defaults, right? This is the defaults.
Power bar strength 10, swing strength
zero. Right? Power bar bullish colors
cyan, magenta.
Signal triangle offset in ticks, trade
parameters, enabled trade validity two,
trade entry two. Now, I'll just keep all
that as a default to start with, okay?
So,
let's just uh make this chart a little
bit bigger so you can see.
Okay, so today, okay?
This is ultra bonds, right?
Now, you'll see power bars, bearish ones
are colored magenta.
Right? Bullish ones are colored cyan.
Again, I just explained you can change
those colors.
And you're going to see
triangles
after the power bars, right? If the
triangle comes in, then that signal is
confirmed.
Right? If there's no
triangle, in this case up, no cyan
triangle, that power bar is not
confirmed, okay? And I'll want to talk
about that in a minute, but that's under
the trade entry signal. And basically,
what that means is if it's not
confirmed, it's telling you the order
flow, the value, everything in the this
bar is bullish,
but what happens afterwards
is not bullish. I don't want to say it's
bearish, but it's not following through
the way it should, meaning
um you know, you and I, right? We're
small traders. You know, we trade
anywhere between one to five lots. You
know, some of you guys maybe trade 10,
15.
But, we're nothing compared to the big
institutional traders, the guys flipping
around, you know,
hundreds of contracts at a time or even
the really big guys that get you know,
get the big orders to you know, trade
5,000 at a clip.
And if you're trading your your two
lots, three lots, and then some guy
comes in, you know, you're long,
you just bought two, but some guy comes
in with an order to sell 5,000. Well,
you're going to get stuffed, right?
You're going to get your head handed
back to you on a tray.
Um
and you're going to get stopped out,
right? So, that's what these
the trade entry signal deals with,
right? So,
for example,
it's right here, trade entry signal.
It's enabled, okay? So,
if I disable it, I just uncheck it,
right? I click apply.
All right, so you see that disappeared.
Now, you're going to see every power bar
is going to have a triangle above or
below it, right? If it's bullish, it's
going to be below. If it's bearish, it's
going to be above. Okay, that is good,
but again, you're going to want the
follow through order flow, right? Here
is a bullish power bar,
but there was no follow through order
flow here, right? It just turned around
and sold off.
Here's a bullish power bar, didn't go
any higher.
higher.
Okay? So, I like to use the trade entry
signal as a filter to tell me that when
the trades are coming in,
that you know,
there's follow through order flow,
right? Now,
click apply. So, when you click it,
right? It doesn't open up till you click
apply.
Now, it appears, so you could adjust
this. So, trade val- valid in number of
bars is two. That's basically
over the next two bars after the signal
bar, there has to be follow through
order flow within those two bars, right?
It could happen in the next bar or the
bar afterwards.
Now again, you don't have to use two.
You could use any number. You could use
five. Uh I wouldn't go higher than five.
So, that would mean within the next five
bars, there has to be
follow through order flow in the
direction of the signal.
Now, trade entry in ticks means market's
got to move two ticks, right? Default is
set to two.
It's a lower moving market, you can set
it to one.
Okay, so, either one is fine. Um
I use two and two is mine, but you can
adjust them. You know, say you want to
use five and two or three and one.
It's up to you.
But, what that does, all right, is
that just gives you an extra filter,
right? Telling you,
"Yeah, you got your bullish order flow
here, but there was no follow through
order flow afterwards, right? You got
your bearish order flow in this bar.
Then yes, you do have your bearish order
flow coming in in this bar.
You get short, you know, at at 31,
right? And it makes that move all the
way down to 20s, you know, 19."
Here you got bullish order flow, but no
follow through. Bullish order flow, but
no follow through.
You know, if you're just trading every
signal
blind, you're going to get chopped up.
You're going to be in trades you
shouldn't be taking. And you know, most
traders when they they start trading,
you know, everyone comes in, "Oh, I got
this great moving average crossover
system. You know, when this line
crosses, you know, the 200 crosses over
the 50,
you buy or you sell."
Well, you know,
there's a lot of times that you're just
getting chopped up, all right? Cuz they
don't know how to filter out trades,
right? There's no
Well, there's no one you know, there's
there's no reason to take those trades
other than one line crosses the other,
you know, you're not getting any follow
through in the terms of order flow,
right? You want to be going in the
direction that people are buying or
people are selling,
right? And that's where the trade entry
signal is comes in, right? It's telling
you,
"Get long here because yeah, you have
your bullish order flow in the power bar
and the market's starting to move in
that direction,
right?" Now, people will say, "Well,
yeah, this big power bar here. Shouldn't
I just get long cuz it's it's so you
know, it's power bars, right? It's a big
bar. It's powerful, isn't it?" Well,
there still needs to be that follow
through order flow. Someone could just
had a big order they had to fill here.
You know, I mean, there's guys that will
just you know, they'll get an order on
the trading desk,
"Uh buy me 50 you know, buy me 500 ultra
bonds." Okay, boom. They just buy
everything all the way up to 28. You're
filled.
Uh then the market just drops back down
again, you know? They're they're not
good at
their execution, so to speak, right? And
you know, if you're just reacting to
that big order going through the market,
well, you're going to get hung, all
right? And and that's not what you want
to do,
right? You want to be trading, taking
the trades where you got the follow
through order flow, right? Here, follow
through order flow down, follow through
order flow back up, follow through order
flow back down.
All right? This is today in the ultra
bonds, right? People will say, "Well,
you know, you just picked a good
market." Well, let's take a look at the
previous day. I mean, even overnight,
right? The same
rules would apply, right?
Even though you got, you know, bullish
order flow here, bearish, you want to be
taking the trades where it's confirmed,
right? You got the bullish power bar,
bearish power bars, but you want to take
the ones that are being confirmed with
the follow through order flow. Look at
this, bullish bullish order flow,
bullish, but it's on a bar by bar basis,
okay? But over here, it's telling you
you got the bearish order flow
and you got the bearish follow through
order flow,
right? You know, that's the difference,
right? Difference between getting
stopped out trade, two trades, three
trades, four trades,
when you should just be short
on this entire move down.
So, you know, previous day.
Again, um
I don't have the date on here. Let's add
it on.
Just click on properties.
Uh where is it? Show date range here.
Close that down.
Okay, there. So, you could see uh 622.
Again, a nice little I'll say nice
little move down. But yeah, there's a
little sideways move down, a little move
up here, some moves down.
You know, here's a move up. Here's this
little move down here, move up. Now,
ultra bonds again, you know, I sent a
nice email out yesterday about scalping
the ultra bonds. You know, that I find
ultra bonds is a great scalper's market
because you know, it trades
it each tick is 3125 and
you know,
if you make four ticks, that's already
um what is that? It's like 125
bucks, right? You don't need to be
making 10 points, 20 points, 30 points.
You know, you could be scalping in and
out, four points here, three points
there, four points there.
At the end of three or four trades,
you're you know, you're you're you're
already got your $400, right? Your $500.
That's it. You know, you don't need to
be sitting in front of a screen all day.
You catch four points here, four points
down here, you get stopped out here,
another four points here. Um you know,
another four points there, right? You're
done. It's 9:00 in the morning, 10:00 in
the morning.
All right? Now,
uh email today I got, someone asked me
specifically
to talk about soybeans. Okay? Now, you
know, not everybody trades soybeans. You
know, everyone likes to come to the
markets. Uh you know, the Nasdaq, you
know, cuz it moves around a lot, you
know, it's great. You know, I'm on top
step trader, I trade Nasdaq, I trade
e-minis. Well, there's so many other
markets that move beautifully. All
right, especially that follow order flow
beautifully. Um
you know, you don't need to be
you know, trading and feeling like
you've just been wrestling with the
market for an hour, you know, or when
you
my trading Nasdaq, right? You trade some
of these other markets that that move
quite nicely. Now, here's soybeans
today, okay?
We just go back. You know, soybeans open
up at 8:30
right in here. You know, nice move up,
nice move down. Now,
let's get into some of these settings
here. There's not many settings,
honestly. I've tried to keep it as clean
as possible, right? Cuz you know, people
get confused with so many different you
know, I I released an indicator on
absorption.
It's a great indicator,
but I set up different types of
absorption that that you could look for
in the indicator. I think there's eight
different types of absorption, and
everyone wants to click all eight of
them. Well,
you know, you're going to find
absorption in
it got too messy and too confusing for a
lot of people.
Um so, I I try to keep things simple now
in a sense of on the back end, you know,
what you're looking at on the actual
footprint
is in here, right? Try to keep it as
simple as possible.
Um so, you're going to have a couple
things to deal with here. Basically, the
power bar strength and swing strength.
Now,
power bar strength,
even though we write 10 to 85, it's
actually 0 to 100, but you're not going
to use 0. If you're going to use 0, you
might as well not use the indicator at
all. I mean, what's the point of having
a strength set to 0, okay? Um 100 is
going to be too strong. You probably not
going to get any signals.
So, you know, 10 to 85. Yeah, you can
actually use five, but five is is very
weak. So, you know, I set it to 10 to
85. 50 would be about the midpoint.
Okay? And again, it's not about using uh
13 or 52. You know, you can use, you
know, 10, 25, 30, 35, you know, 50, 65,
70, 75, like that, 85. Um but you know,
the main ones should be 10,
you know, maybe 30 or 35, I don't know.
Um
50,
you know, 65, 75, like that. I don't go
around trying to finesse all this market
is is 48, like that. No, you know,
you shouldn't have to curve fit that
much
anything. So, 50, okay? So, 50 is you
know, it's about moderate strength.
Okay?
And you could see here, right?
There's a nice buy here. Here's your
nice sells here. You know, this buy
didn't work. People say, "Oh, yeah,
yeah, this buy here didn't work." Well,
okay, you got stopped out. You know,
that happens.
But then, you got to be able to take the
next trade, right? You're getting short
around the 05 area before it drops down
literally 10 cents.
Excuse me.
Drink some water.
Sorry for coughing, but um
you know, it's set to 50 right now,
okay? And you're seeing, okay, you know,
here's a trade went sideways, here's a
trade didn't work out. Then you get
another bullish buy here, right? You got
a nice
you know, four or five 4-cent move,
5-cent move there. Now,
the way you would trade it, okay, people
say, "Where are you going to place your
you know, you're going to get short,
you're going to place your stop where?"
Well, I have a bearish power bar here,
okay?
If it's a bearish bar, you know,
you're going to get short, and then you
can put in a buy stop. Where are you
going to put your buy stop? On the other
side of that power bar. So, in this
case, the power bar high is 9 and a
quarter.
So, my stop should be up here at 9 and a
half.
Then we want to give a little room, 9
and 3/4. But definitely
just above that high of that that
particular power bar, just as bullish
one here, right? You're going to get
this is your bullish power bar here,
all right? The low is uh
13 double 0 and a quarter.
So, your stop is going to be here, 13
double 0
or double uh 99 and 3/4 right here. It's
up to you. I I use the
one tick below. I don't use the exact
low. I use it um you know, one tick
below, you know, just that's why this
one here would have stopped you out,
right? You're getting long
right in here at 07. You you your stop
is at
four and 3/4. You get stopped out. Okay,
get short here, all right? You're
getting short at, you know, four and
3/4. Your stop is just right here at six
and a half.
Okay?
You buy it here,
98 and a half, 98 and 3/4. Your sell
stop is right here, 96 and a quarter. It
just goes sideways, all right? Before
eventually comes down and ends and you
know, would stop you out. But again, if
you're in a trade and it's just going
sideways, you're you're in at 9:42, and
it's 10:00, and it's just
going nowhere. You know,
you got to be asking yourself, should
you still be in that trade? Me, I I like
to give it five 10 you know, on a minute
base chart, I only give it five or 10
minutes. I don't wait
an hour for it to go in my favor.
Um I expect the moves to start
happening, you know, pretty soon.
Not like this, right? You're getting
long here, then it's just you know,
another minute, three, four, five, six,
you know, before Well, here, this one
stopped you out right here.
But still, you know, here, you're
getting long. It comes back down,
doesn't stop you out cuz your stop is
here at
five. The low is five and a quarter of
this bar. Your stop is at five.
And then it makes that move up to um
you know, 02.
I definitely have a price target in
mind. Now,
this is
soybeans, right? I mean, and you know,
you can
soybeans don't you know, aren't as
active as, you know, equities overnight,
but you know, there's still trades to be
had, you know? There's nothing wrong
with scalping at 5:00 in the morning a
couple cents if you can.
You know, scalping from, you know, five
and a quarter down to four and a
quarter.
It's a 50
you know, or even in here, right?
Getting short
you know, what? 8 and a half?
You know, even in here,
eight and 3/4.
It's a nice move down,
you know, four and a half.
But you know, it's
here's some buys and trade signals
did not trigger, right? That's why we
have this trade entry signal,
right? Cuz there could be
bearish order flow bars, power bars,
right?
But it's not moving two ticks
over the next two bars, right? It only
moves Here's the power bar, right? The
low is two and a quarter, the bearish
power bar. It only goes down to two and
two and a quarter. You know, I said the
low is I'm sorry, two and a half. It
only got as low as two and a quarter.
All right? And then it just went
sideways, right? That's not a trade you
want to take. Just as this is not a
trade you want to take, right? Bullish
power bar, but no follow through order
flow. Could have just been a big order.
Maybe somebody you know, hey, sell me
50. It is 1:30 in the morning, sell me
50 beans or buy me 50 beans. Okay, they
did.
Then the market goes nowhere.
Okay?
So,
you know, go back previous day.
Cuz someone will say, "Well, you're just
showing that because it was a nice
move." No, I mean, someone asked me for
that.
So, here's, you know, again, the
previous day,
this is uh the 22nd, all right?
Market opens up 8:30 here, works its way
down. Okay, you got bearish power bar,
does nothing.
It just sort of goes, it triggers, all
right?
Then it's three candles up, then another
down. And then again, it can't go any
further down. Then you got a bullish
power bar. Now, no buy triggered here,
right? You don't have that
cyan triangle here
because
it didn't go any higher over the next
two bars. Finally, it did here, right?
Here you got your bullish
power bar, and finally
it
before
you know, but you'd be long, right? So,
the high of this bar is 10 and 3/4. So,
you
two ticks over the next two bars is 11
and a quarter.
So, you're getting long here, 11 and a
quarter. You took a couple, you know, a
little bit of heat down to 10
before boom, it moves from 11 and a
quarter all the way up to
I mean, in this case, you know, 22. It's
a 10-cent move in
what? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 minutes?
Right? And then boom, you get your
bearish power bar here. It's a quick
drop here, then it move back up.
Right? Bearish power bar,
sideways, comes down a little bit.
Um this one would have stopped you out.
Didn't go any further.
Here's one, you know, it would have
reversed you here, went back up.
Couple power bars, dropped down.
Some bullish power bar, came back into
the power bar, but didn't stop you out
before going higher. Then you got the
bearish one, and it dropped from
you know, what is that level? 21, 20 and
3/4.
Well, you know, all the way down, even
though you got bullish power bar here,
no follow through. Then bearish bearish
all bearish signs, bearish bearish
bearish
bearish.
You know, this is what this area is
here? What? 20 and 3/4, 20 and a half,
all the way down
down down down.
It's just down, you know, even if you
missed that,
even if you missed your your short in
here, right? Cuz your stop should just
be,
you know, 22 and a half or 22 and a
quarter is the high here. 22 and a half
is the high right here.
You should
you know, you're not stopped out, all
right? So, you missed this trade for
whatever reason, fine. You take this
trade here, or even this trade here.
You're still catching a beautiful move.
Okay?
And then it closed in here.
But, um you know,
that's soybeans, right? But, you know,
again, there's so many different markets
to trade besides S&P's and Nasdaq, you
know. Well, and it it's more glamorous
to say you're just you're a Nasdaq
trader or an S&P trader than
you know, soybean trader, but you know
what? Soybeans
up until start of
mini S&P's, I think soybeans I made more
millionaires than than any other market.
But, um it's great market to trade cuz
it follows order flow really well. Now,
here's
mini Dow, right? I'm I'm just using the
same settings that I was just showing
you on the other market, right? 50.
Power bar strength, 50, which is sort of
its midpoint.
All right?
Swing strength. Now, I'm going to get
into that in a minute. I have set to
zero, okay?
I'm going to talk about swing strength
later, but you can see, right? Late in
the day,
all right? You got this nice move down
from
where?
30, you know, the low of this power bar
is what? 39. So, you know, two ticks
would be 37. Say you get filled at the
worst price, 35, 36.
All right? A little bit of heat, only up
to 43.
But, you're getting short, you know,
call it 36, all the way down to the cash
close, you know, you're probably going
to get out a little bit before the cash
close, but down to the 80 area, right in
here.
All right? That's what? 50 points. Now,
that was the late move, but you know,
let's just go back to the beginning of
the day here. Where is the beginning?
8:30.
Okay? So, you got a little bit of sell
signals coming in right on, you know,
right ahead of the cash open. Cash open,
obviously you got a big bar.
You know, it's not advisable to trade
the first few minutes of the cash open,
um cuz you get a lot of bars like this,
where they're all over the place. 35 all
the way up to What is that? You know,
900. It's a 70 65 point bar, right? You
know, that's not where you want to be
getting involved in the market.
All right? It'd be nice if you shorted
it up here, but you know, the reality is
most people are going to get short down
here and then get stopped out up there.
Yeah, you let the market calm down, get
some normal bars forming, and you get a
little sell here. Okay, you got to buy
that. Unfortunately, it didn't really do
much, you know, then again, tried
another buy here. Again, not doing much,
and then boom, you get a nice buy here,
right? This one,
you know, it's from the 22 area all the
way up into the 70s.
You know, it's a nice 50 point move up,
followed by what? You know, a nice move
down, but unfortunately though, this one
would have stopped you out because I
used my
I used the high of the power bar right
here
as my stop level. You know, so
79 is the high. I would use 81, 82 as my
stop, and it just stopped me out before
it fell over.
This one did nothing, then you got a
little move here. This one just went
sideways, little move up here. It's not
this power bar you're buying, you're
buying it off of this one here. The move
down.
Sideways.
Again,
little bit of a move up, nice move down.
Doesn't
look like much, but this is about a 30
40 point drop right there.
Uh
little you know, a little sideways back
and forth, you know, this is
again, I'm just using the same rough
settings as before, you know, depending
on the market, you're probably going to
want to adjust it, right? It's all, you
know,
you got your power bar, bearish power
bar right here.
All right? Before that big bar where it
drops from, you know, 16 area down to
you know, 01.
Now, again, the settings, all right? So,
I explained
oops, let's be serious. The settings,
the
50 is about mid mid-level, okay? You
could go as high as you could go as high
as I don't say 100, you know, it'll be
99, but I wouldn't go over 85.
75 is about as high as I would go. So,
let's take a look at at 75. You're going
to see less signals, obviously, the
higher the strength is
um
that you go, okay? So, you can see now,
you know, do you see any signals? Not
many.
You know, here's a buy here.
Here's a sell here. Here's a buy there.
You know, if I was going on a higher
higher strength
power bar strength, I would use it more
for scalping just the next few ticks
rather than trying to catch big moves.
It's not correlated in that sense. It's
There's some power
in the market, but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to always go
on in that direction to infinity. Okay?
Now, if you use a lower number, 10,
especially on a market as volatile as
say YM,
you're going to get a lot of signals,
right? Up here, down here, up here, down
here. Now, if I was using
a lower power bar strength, right? 10,
I would use swing strength.
Okay? Because
you're going to get a lot of signals,
but now this time what you want to do is
you want to use
uh
and
you know, you want to take in more bars
into the the
equation, so to speak, right? And swing
swing strength does is it looks over
additional bars, okay? So, if setting it
to one, zero is basically to disable it.
Setting it to one
is the the lowest you can do once it's
turned on. Entering a value turns it on,
basically. Zero disables it cuz it's not
looking at anything. But, one,
you know, on a market that's volatile
and you have a low power bar strength is
is a good idea. So, let's set it at 10
and one. Now, if I had it at 75 and one,
I'm probably going to get very few
signals.
But, let's go with 10 and one and and
take a look.
All right, so
you can see here, right? Now, it's
looking for swing highs and swing lows,
right? It's looking over a swing period,
so you can see
you know, here's at 8:14, you got a buy,
okay? A little bit move up, and then
boom, you know, 8:17, you got the sell.
It's a nice move down. Now, this is why
we use the trade entry signals because
you see here,
all right? You see the cyan bar, but it
doesn't go any higher. Cyan bar doesn't
go any higher, that's why you don't see
those triangles. So, it's keeping you
short, and it's keeping you out of these
losing trades here. All right? Now, you
know, here, you got this little move
down. Got this nice move up. Again, it
doesn't look like much at this time cuz
this market's pretty volatile, but you
know,
here's your power bar here at the swing
low.
And the high of this power bar is what?
29. So, you're using two ticks, so
that'd be 31. You're getting long at the
highest of this bar, 31.
All right? And then it sort of closes
back down a little bit. And you're long
from 31.
It goes from 31 all the way up to 70.
What is that? 75. It's a 40 point move
there.
All right? Then nothing on this move
down. Okay, you know, some people they
want to expect order flow to give them
every single movement in the market.
Well,
that's more advanced order flow. That's
where you're going to be looking at a
footprint chart, right? And and trying
capturing these moves, right? And you're
not going to see it on a dome, all
right? Right now,
um
you know, this is the dome, right? Now,
granted, it's it's 5:44 at night, and
it's pretty quiet. All right? Market is
dead right now. But, during the day,
things are moving around very quickly,
right?
Right now, the market is is
it's
very quiet, um since the reopen, you
know, here,
you know, it just moved. It's not moving
right now. But, you can see it moving,
but during the day, it's
you know, it
it's uh it's moving all over the place,
all right?
And you know, someone said, "Well, the
reason you should really scalp." Cuz I
sent that email out about scalping.
Um ultra bonds, this is a nice market to
scalp cuz you got to look at a dome,
right? You can't look at an indicator.
Well, if you're looking at a dome,
right? You need a trigger, something to
tell you to take a trade,
okay? And if you're not
taking that trade based on
whatever reason, you're just trying to
figure it out on a dome, well, when a
dome is
not moving, it's a lot easier than
during the main session where the
market's moving faster. Now, yeah,
granted, if you're Rain Man or somebody,
you know, that can count, you know, a
20 deck shoe in blackjack, yeah, okay,
great. Good on you. But, majority of
people, you know, can't, all right? I've
been looking at a dome since the early
days of Globex when I left the trading
floor in the 90s, right?
I've been I traded on the old Globex
system.
And you know, there was a dome back
then. You know, we used to go sweep the
order book in there. We could see where
the size was, and we'd sweep it, and
things like that, and you know, we'd do
all all sorts of stuff back in those
days in the sense of, you know, I mean,
in those days at night session, you
know, that's
when S&P's were trading 400. Um you
know, a 20 lot was considered a very big
order. But, um
you know, now it it just market moves
too fast on on a dome for the majority
overwhelming majority of traders, right?
You need something
to trigger them to get into a trade. Cuz
they don't say, "Well, yeah, you know,
when the big size flashes in the dome,
you know, then you're going to you know,
you jump in front of it. Well,
try and stare at a dome
all day long now.
You're going to
want to bang your head against the wall
trying to figure stuff out. You mean
it's nice and you see stuff and it
happens and you're right, but all day
long trying to be that consistent is
hard for a lot of traders and you need
tools
that's going to help you, right?
Like this bar, right? This is the bar
from 22 all the way down to 92, right?
Uh what's that? 30 point down bar,
right? This is the trade you want and
you're getting the signal right before
that move, right? You see this
bearish power bar right here and you
know, right? If you have the bearish
signal, you want to be getting short,
okay, but
you got the bearish power bar, but
you don't get the triangle till the next
bar when it moves two ticks. As soon as
it moves two ticks, that's when it's
going to print. Now, if you have the
trade entry signal turned off,
okay?
Right? It's disabled there.
Now, what you're seeing is you're seeing
the signal on the power bar, right? Just
as you're seeing the signal here,
here, right? Here, here.
Well, that's all well and good,
but you know, you probably don't want to
be taking that trade and and you know, I
know people get excited, you know, they
see a big bar or they see some movement
in the market and they want to get long
or get short. You got to wait for the
bar to close and you know, I see it with
people trading you know, 5 minute bar,
10 minute bar, halfway into the bar,
they're already thinking, "Oh, it's very
bearish. I got to get short." Right?
They're trading at a 10 minute bar.
They get short after 6 minutes. Well,
the last 4 minutes, everything changes
in the bar that becomes from very
bearish to very bullish, right? And but
they got short already because the first
6 minutes was very bearish.
Well, they shouldn't be trading a
you know, 5 minute bar or a 10 minute
bar like that. They might as well be
trading a 5 minute bar
because what's what's the point is
things change in a bar, right? If you've
ever watched
how bars form, you know, they they don't
just go straight up or straight down.
They go up and down, up and down, up and
down before they finally close, right?
So, you need the bar to close. And then
you need the follow through order flow.
So, that's why we have this trade entry
signal. Again, you don't have to use it.
If you're a scalper, you might want not
want to use it. Just see every signal.
That's two and two.
And then just trade them, right? But
again, you could just trade every signal
and drop in a sell stop right here. You
know, I got a bearish bar forming. Okay,
I could be ready if this market breaks,
you know, 20, I could be sitting here
with a sell stop already entered,
right? Or you could have it, you know,
tell you that, "Hey, you know what?
There's a signal for you to take."
Okay? So, here is a bearish power bar,
but no
follow through order flow. That's why
you don't get that signal. Here is one.
It started going down, but it reversed,
right? Went back up. That would have
stopped you out. Okay, fine.
You get stopped out in trading, right?
Nothing is 100% perfect. You know, I
wish I could say this is 100% perfect,
but I know I've
traded long enough
on my whole professional career
to know that nothing is certain. You
know, I know you could have all the best
information. Oh, everything is just
perfect lined up, but for whatever
reason, conditions change and they even
change not just on a macro level, but on
a micro level, right? I I
you know, over the next 10 seconds,
things can change. Something can come
out.
You know, Trump's not president anymore,
so he's not tweeting. He's banned from
Twitter, but you know, you don't know
what it's like, you know, you're you're
trading the markets happily, you know,
you're you're you're up 4 500 bucks.
Also, next thing you know, boom, you're
stopped out. You lost everything and and
an extra 100 bucks because why? You
don't know yet until later. Oh, Trump
tweeted something, right?
And that's why, you know, wait for the
confirmation of the bar to close.
You know, here is a nice sell right
here, right? Here's your nice
bar get short on, right? And you get the
follow through order flow.
You know, from 70 all the way down to I
don't want to say double low, but you
know, at least down in here to, you
know, the 20 area, 10 20 area. Little
move up, little move down, little
sideways. You know, there's a short that
didn't work. Here was Well, you should
have been short here. People say, "Well,
the short didn't work." Well, you had
you just had your short signal 10 bars
earlier at, you know, 30 points higher.
That's the short you should have taken.
Um you know, here is a long.
Okay? I don't know if
I don't know how this bar formed. I
don't know if this low was put in before
or after
this bar
um
you know, moved cuz lots of times you're
going to see, you know, with the trade
entry signal, it can go up and down,
back and forth,
but you know, if I had my stop here at
74 and this low was formed,
you know,
after we made that move up, then yeah,
that would stop me out, but there's
times where the bars come in, make that
new low and then trade higher. That that
wouldn't stop you out.
Um you know, then you catch that move
up. You know, again, here's something
that's going sideways. Now, again, this
market's going sideways, but you get
short
in here and then it just goes sideways
for the next 20 minutes.
You shouldn't be stuck in a trade for 20
minutes if it's going nowhere. You know,
that's your sign to get out of the
trade. And this is where it gets
interesting, right? You got your bearish
power bar, bearish power bar, bearish
power bar.
So, no follow through order flow here.
No follow through order flow here.
Finally, you got that follow through
order flow here.
But you can see the signs that things
were bearish. 1 2 3 4 5 before it
finally broke and when it broke,
you know, it broke
you know, close to 40 points, you know,
from 05 down to 65,
right? Then the move back up here,
right? You're buying it in here, right?
The high of this power bar
is
87, so you're getting long around 88 89
90.
Your stop is down here at 78 or sorry,
77, right? The low was 78.
Blow you know, you should be getting
your stop at 77. Now, it's not uncommon
for a bar to pull back into the power
bar, right? Cuz the power bar is is a
measure of value, right? And you know
that
as you break out from value, you can
retrace back into value,
decide whether it's going to accept it
or reject it and move away, right? And
it came back into value,
you know, back into, you know, the 83
area, 82 81
before going all the way up into the
20s.
Right? 30s.
Now, there's different ways to trade it.
Me, I like to trade
I like to get in as soon as the market
moves in that direction, right? As soon
as I got that follow through order flow,
I'm getting in. But if I'm scaling into
the market, right? Cuz now with the
micros, you can do that. You got a
little bit more flexibility,
right? So, you know, you get in
a few contracts right away. Then you
could stack some bids in here. Wait for
that pull back to come in
and you know, average your price on your
fill. I mean, your stop is still going
to be here, right? It's not that if I'm
buying it in here at 82, I'm going to
you know, put it at a lower stop. No,
you know, my the power bar is my stop.
Right? And then it went back up. Um
you know, here it just sort of went
sideways on you. Again, it's trying to
break, doesn't really break.
You know, that should be your sign. You
know, trading is not an exact science,
right? There's some science to it, but
it's not rocket science, okay? And
you know,
it doesn't it takes some common sense.
Okay, yeah, I've got my bearish power
bar here. Yeah, it's come off about four
or five ticks, rallies back up, doesn't
stop me out, makes another move down
here,
um down to 05. Like it can't break any
further, you know, then it's like,
"Well, what do you want to do?" Well,
this was your move, right? You're
expecting a move.
Made a small one and then pulled back,
then tried to make a bigger one and it's
starting to pull back. Okay? You get
out, right? You don't wait for it to
come back all the way back up here to
stop you out.
You know, if it's not making that move,
you know, you move your your stop to
break even so you're not getting stopped
out at the full loss
or, you know, maybe a little bit, you
know, take a smaller loss, but
you don't want it to come all the way
back up and stop you out, right? I mean,
that's trading, okay?
Um you know, it's got nothing to do with
power bars. It's got to do with with
trading, understanding trading.
But again, you know,
there's a move here, right? It's sort of
back and forth, you know, you maybe
getting long in here, but then you got
the bearish sign in here.
Keeps you short, you know, a little back
and forth. So, you know, you're you're
sort of grinding your wheels, right?
You're getting short in here and then
you got your bullish sign here and
you're getting long, you know, from the
97 98 area
all the way up to, you know, late in the
day when you're trading.
You know, this is 30, you know, say you
you don't want to wait till the cash
close.
You know, you get your long in here from
95 96 trading 25. You're happy. It's 30
points.
Excuse me.
Mm, sorry there. I just had a little
coughing attack. I think I caught one
cough on recording, but uh before I was
able to pause it. But again, you know,
you could see, you know, sort of this
the flexibility
in
the indicator. Again, you know, if
you're a scalper, let's take a look at
some other these scalper markets.
Honestly, I haven't looked at
bonds
in the last couple of days, last 2 days
or so.
So, I I've been on the road a lot. So,
this is a 1 minute chart in the bonds.
You get a lot of this, right? Bonds, you
know, that's
I used to love trading bonds. Um I was
sort of moved into ultra bonds, but you
get a lot of this bid offer, right?
Trading. I like these markets that don't
move around a lot sometimes cuz they
give good opportunities. You only got to
get quick hits. Here was a nice little
quick hit. But
what do I got the setting at? I would
turn off
I would turn off swing strength on a
market like bonds, right?
I would just turn it off because I want
to see as many signals as possible.
But I still keep the trade entry signal
on, right? So you've seen the trade
entry signal there.
Some bearish bars, but you're not seeing
any short opportunities there.
You know, here's a nice short in here.
You know, the 29 area. It did pull back
a little bit to 31, pull back to ticks
before it dropped from 29 all the way
down to 19.
Um
This was just today. Honestly, I didn't
look at this market till just now,
right? Here was a nice little short
here. But again, on bonds, you know, I'm
happy to scalp three or four ticks
at a time. Now,
this is a
1-minute chart and you know, honestly,
you're not going to trade you can't get
any information whether you're trading
order flow or anything on
1 minutes in the bonds where it's just
flatline like that, right?
Trade just one price.
You know, I I know people that they like
to use 2 minutes, 3 minutes, um you
know, 5 minutes you could even use on
bonds. But again, if you're you're
scalping bonds, you really want to be on
a on a
short enough time frame to catch some
decent moves. You know, 5 minutes, you
know, when you're dealing with the order
flow, okay? The issue is
freshness of data, right? You don't want
to be trading something that
happened an hour ago, 2 hours ago,
right? You want to be trading based on
what's happening right now.
Now,
this is bonds on a 5-minute chart. Now,
that's not to say that you can't, but it
depends on the type of trading that
you're doing, right? Maybe you you know,
you want to trade a longer time frame,
30 minutes. You can as well, but that's
a different style of trading, right? And
then it's not how I trade, but depending
on on
other people, you know,
you you could see, right? This nice move
up, nice move up, nice move down, right?
It's it's a different type of trading
for people, okay? This is a 30-minute
chart. So imagine,
you know, you the flexibility that
you're going to see in in different
markets, right? Now,
you know, people ask, "Well, what about,
you know, these these other markets?
Like I I don't trade futures, you know,
I trade
um
other things, you know, I trade uh
I don't know,
Apple."
Oh, I don't have the right uh the
quote feed. This is my
Continuum quote feed. So let me just
switch over real quick on the quote feed
here.
Uh
Go over from there. Let's go to Kinetic.
Kinetic.
Kinetic sand. Um
Now, okay.
Connected here. So this is Apple, all
right?
Uh what do I got on here?
Uh
10 and 0, okay? So the default settings.
So it's going to give me signals
you know, in a rapid I don't say fast
and furious, but you know, pretty quick.
So let's sort of break it down. It says
calculating, so it's still calculating.
You know, just it's going over the
historical data, obviously. Um
you don't need tick data enabled, but um
let's see what comes up here.
Let's see I
give it a second here to calculate. It's
the first time I I have Apple data on
this computer, so that's why it's taking
a bit a bit longer than
the normal.
So just bear with me here.
Okay.
Do do do
Okay, so here it's come back up. Uh
what do I do? So again, let's take a
look at the settings.
And
NinjaTrader's freezing up on me cuz it's
trying to read the data for my futures
charts. Uh
So you got to
love-hate relationship with NinjaTrader.
When I change the data feed, it's uh
it's slowing everything down
initially because I got all my futures
charts it's trying to uh
pull up the historical data for. So uh
so 10 and 0, okay? Now,
a lot of signals, okay, fine. I'm seeing
basically every single signal,
right? That's that's being generated.
Again, this is Apple, right? A lot of
people like to day trade Apple. I mean,
you're seeing some nice moves
up, nice moves down. Just keeping you
out of these trades that you shouldn't
be in here and here.
Um yeah, I mean, are there some losers?
Yeah, here's a loser here, here's a
loser there. But you catch this nice
move up from the swing low. I mean, you
know, at 13340,
you know, all the way up into 134.
All right? You know,
there's a lot of people out there that
that trade stocks, they just want to
make, you know,
25, 30 cents
per stock.
You know, they they trade 100 lots and
they're done, right? You have your your
opportunity to make your 25 cents, your
50 cents
back and forth all day long, right? This
is Apple.
Okay, so you have excuse me, you know,
there are
there are um you know, opportunities
there, right? Whether you're trading
stocks, uh futures,
Well, let's see. I'm I'm on
my Kinetic connection. So let's take a
look at uh
uh forex. I don't know. Um
Let's look at Euro Japanese yen.
I don't want to look at Euro USD cuz
that's very that's basically looking at
6E.
Um
But uh let's take a look here.
Is it up yet?
It's still calculating.
Okay.
This is right now is Euro USD, okay?
It's I don't know what time it is. It's
6:03 p.m.
Wednesday night.
Okay? So the market just this You say,
"Oh, you got a short here and failed."
Well, the market closed, right? Right
here, this essentially.
I know it's forex trades 24 hours, you
know, the reopen is right here.
All right? So you catch that nice little
move up, little move down, little move
up. But you know, during the day
session,
you know, how did it look? What am I
looking at? 1-minute chart.
All right? This nice move here. Again,
more move down, move up. Euro USD,
obviously, you know, there are certain
times of the day I think it's going to
trade better.
Um you know, but it moved from what?
13244 to here, you know, down to 13237.
There's a lot of
movement, right? To be had. Now, this
one is kind of tight or sorry, kind of
loose cuz it's set to 10.
So maybe, you know, you want to add a a
swing filter, set it to one. Look, not
10, but set it to one.
And
let's see here.
Okay, so here's your bearish power bar
followed by a bullish one, which caught
that move.
Couple bearish ones here, there's
bullish one. Unfortunately, what is
like stopped you out.
Here's a little move here, some moves
here, moves up here.
Again, you know, you could adjust it,
you know, maybe you say 10 is
10 is too loose, okay? So, you know, you
want to change that to zero, use a
higher swing filter. Again, it depends
on the market you're trading, right?
There's no
perfect setting for every single market,
you know, markets are trade differently,
you know? Here it's set to 50 and 0,
okay? Right?
50 and 0.
You you're seeing some better trade
opportunities here and here.
Okay?
Here, catch this nice move down, right?
All the way down from 13250
six, you know, all the way down down
down. You know, you get your first
bullish signal here at 44.
Okay? So, you know, there's there's
plenty of opportunity to be had um
there.
So the the
final thing I want to talk about, talk
about Bitcoin, okay? Now, on
NinjaTrader,
there's a
Let me get my control panel up here.
Control center.
And disappeared on me.
Okay.
Here we go.
Disconnect this. This is my Kinetic
setting.
Go to configure. Now, you get get data
from
Coinbase, okay?
So you got to add it. You got to set it
up here, right? You just click on it.
It'll come up here and it'll appear down
here under configured.
Okay? Just click apply.
You don't need it to start up on connect
on startup. Just connect it when you
connect.
Okay, click apply. So you have it set up
in there, Then you got to connect to it.
So, you click
connect to
Coinbase, okay?
Then that's what these cryptos are here.
So, you got to choose one.
I don't know. Choose Bitcoin.
BTC. Now, it may take a
You know, this one came up pretty quick.
But you can see it's calculating right
now, the indicator.
So,
see how it it comes up. Again, it's the
first time downloaded Coinbase data onto
this PC. So, initial time, the first
time it might take um
a little bit longer than
than normal, okay?
So, just bear with me here.
Now, you know, it's
I'm kind of split on trading crypto and
buying and holding, right? You got to
buy them in hands. So, you know, what
I'm saying? You got to have diamond
hands. You just buy it and you just
forget about it. And then when it goes
down, you just never sell
until it goes back up again. But um
you know, I was buying Bitcoin last
year. I I sold it
around 48 and I started kicking myself
cuz after I sold it at 48, it went back
all the way up to 60. Um
but
you know, then I I got some money in in
some coins. But um
you know, it's funny cuz you know,
people say you got to really trade
crypto or do you just hold it? But um
you know, this indicator
you can
yeah, if you're a trader, right? I have
accounts, you know, Coinbase like at
Kraken. You know, a place like Kraken
you can trade. I wouldn't recommend
trading
active trading on on Coinbase. But um
yeah, you should use a uh
regular crypto exchange for that. You
know, where you can see the depth of
market, the best bid, the best offer.
Coinbase, you know, you you buy it and
then you just you wait for your
confirmations. So, you know what price
you bought it at is. It reminds me of
those old days when you traded stock,
you know,
back in
you know, the I don't say back in the
'70s, but back in the '80s, right? You
call up your broker
and then you wait, you know, you
you tell them to buy the stock and then
you you wait for your
regular mail to come with, you know,
your confirmation of basically the price
you paid. Um you know, that's
pre-internet days.
And you know, Coinbase is like, okay,
I'm going to buy Bitcoin here and it's
like one of those things you say, well,
I'm filled at a price
that doesn't look like it's even
trading.
All right, so let's give it a second
here. You know, sometimes it's a bit
slow on the data
come up
first few times. Like I adjusted the uh
what do you call it?
The setting there. There we go.
So, you know,
there's some moves, you know, some
decent moves you could catch. Again, I
don't you know, I'm not one that's going
to be advocating, you know, day trading
in and out of of Bitcoin. I mean, you
can,
obviously, but um you know, is that
really what you
you really want to do? Again, this is a
1-minute chart. Yeah, you could pull up,
you know,
5-minute, 15-minutes.
Yeah, 60-minutes.
Um
but again, you know,
the big push down here
yesterday.
Let's see how it looks on the I haven't
looked at the 30-minute chart.
But uh just give it a second here. As I
said, Coinbase, you know, the the data
when it comes in, sometimes it's
it almost feels like it's pulling a
fresh set, you know, unlike, you know,
these other data providers when you
change your chart,
it's just like almost instantly. But
with Coinbase, it feels like it's going
back to Coinbase and pulling fresh data
in.
Um sometimes if that's I don't I don't I
haven't looked at it, but um
on the back end or had my programmer
look into it. But that's what it feels
like sometimes, right? It's just going
out there and all it's got to pull in
the 30-minute data and and sort of
analyze it like that. But um
again, you know, you could use it for
charting
and then just sort of go from there, you
know, it's a
I I really wish,
you know, it's a whole "Please Santa
Claus, can NinjaTrader connect to a real
I won't say real, but you know, a
another crypto exchange besides
Coinbase." Yeah, you can't trade on
Coinbase with a NinjaTrader as far as I
know, but you can
you use the data,
right? But how I wish NinjaTrader would
doesn't have to
pivot, but just open it up, you know?
But I think they're so caught up in
their
um what do you want to call it? Their
NinjaTrader brokerage, right? For
futures
that crypto is not really something that
they're they're thinking about. But who
knows?
You know, um you know, there's a lot of
interest in crypto now because obviously
the last 6 months
it's movement or the last year,
basically. But
you know, if you remember back in 2018
when it crashed from 20,000,
it was dead for the longest time. Um
nobody was interested in in it anymore.
But you know, now that market's gone
back up, everyone seems to be interested
in it again.
I don't know if it's going to stay
there. Again, this is not a
uh what do you want to call it? A
advertisement for for crypto or
anything. But
again, you know, if it's something you
want to analyze, you can. So, let's just
uh
give it a minute here to come back up.
Pause this first.
Okay, you know what? I canceled the
30-minute chart and I pulled up a
5-minute chart instead. Coinbase is
acting too darn slow with NinjaTrader at
this moment um right now. But anyway,
this is a uh 5-minute chart on Bitcoin.
You know, again, it's set at pretty
What's it set at?
Uh forgot the settings. It's been a
50, 75 and two, okay? So,
again, you know, if Bitcoin is one of
those things, you know,
do you really want to be trading in it?
You know, I I don't know. I I see
people, you know, in and out. What is
considered a trade in Bitcoin? You know,
is is it
something you just buy, you know, for me
personally, I just buy. I don't like to
look at the price once I buy it. I just
like to buy it,
sort of forget about it for a while and
then sort of cursory glance at it. Um
cuz you know, trading 24/7, you know, on
the weekends you want to look at it. But
again, you know, if if you're into
trading it or consider trading it,
this is how it looks with the Coinbase.
Now, you know, really quick, well,
probably regret doing this, but um let
me
pull up the CME version.
Um
I promise this presentation will be
ending pretty soon. Let me just
reconnect to um
my futures data
and
pull up
CME should be coming up here.
Do do do.
So,
just give it a sec. So, now it's got to
pull up all my futures data. So, I got
futures charts. A lot of futures charts
on this screen.
But um let me just pause it for a minute
here while it comes up cuz I got like 30
futures charts it's got to
load up with the data. So, just give me
1 sec. I'll I'll just pause it real
quick.
Okay, so anyway, um here's the CME
Bitcoin contract. Again, it's a 1-minute
I'm sorry, no, 5-minute chart.
And
you know, doesn't look too bad if you're
trading the CME contract. Now, they got
the um
micro contracts. Uh
Uh they got almost there in the micros
here.
Nah, let me I forgot what it's called.
Micro
I don't know. I don't say. You know, the
micro Bitcoin contract I was hoping
would
have a lot of volume. So far, it hasn't
yet.
Uh I forgot this forgot the contract
already.
Under Bitcoin. Yeah, sorry.
I I got to uh
sort of get sidetracked a little bit on
this MBT.
This presentation. You know, the earlier
presentation I had some issues
with with the screen.
Anyway, this is um the micro
contract. Um
see right now, it's at 6:45 thereabouts.
Um it's kind of illiquid. But during the
day,
you know,
I don't know. It looks
you could scalp it. Um definitely it's a
5-minute chart. But
you know, not every trade's going to be
a a big winner. If you go I don't Let's
go back to the regular Bitcoin contract.
Um at least that's got some decent
volume
to trade. Again, this is a a 30-minute
chart. I'm I'm kind of curious how it's
going to look on I said it's a 5-minute
chart.
Um a 30-minute chart should come up
decent. Yeah, catch this nice move here
today from you know, I don't know what
that is. 3100
right here
up to you know, 3200. I don't know.
I'm sorry, 3100. 31,000. Sorry.
Up to 32,000 right here. 32,000. Caught
the 33 on that move. Um
you know, caught this move down.
Here was
that probably would have
stopped you out. But this move here,
you know, 31 5.
Gone to 29 5. But again, now this is on
the big contract. Um you know, the micro
is going to be a bit different. But
that's on a 30-minute chart, okay? I
venture to
see what it looks like on a 1-minute
chart. You're probably going to get a
whole lot of nothing. Well, maybe during
the US day session, volume is picking up
a bit on this contract.
Yeah, still not enough volume, I'd say,
on on a 1-minute chart. I mean, there's
trades to be had, but again,
um
nothing to get too enthused about on a
1-minute chart. You probably want to
stick to like a 5-minute chart or
something on there.
But again, um
5-minute on
CME Bitcoin is okay. You can trade that
against, you know, the micro against
that one. Use it as a guide, you know,
you can catch some decent moves, you
know.
30, you know, somewhere in here, 34,000.
All right, you take a little bit of
heat.
34 200 250 all the way down to 33
and change.
33 300 here, 33 400.
Yeah, there's there's moves to be had,
but again, you know,
honestly,
futures provide enough opportunity for
traders, in my opinion,
um that
you know, you you don't need to spread
yourself so thin on a lot of different
markets. So,
go to orderflows.powerbars.com.
www.orderflows.powerbars.com.
This is the page.
Nothing fancy on this one. Um just
scroll down. Again, you could you could
change the colors of your screen. Just
click this button here that says, um I
want power bar.
All right. And it takes you to PayPal.
PayPal processes everything. Once I get
your information, I send it right out to
you.
So, again, thanks, everybody. For those
of you that started watching the
original presentation, I apologize for
what happened.
Um
you should have gotten an email
regarding that, but um
you know, this is the replay, so I hope
you enjoy this replay, and you know, I
hope to hear from you guys soon.
So, thanks, everybody. Bye-bye.